in my head I was thinking I have to do
something very crazy instantly I don't
know why this came to mind but I was
like I would I would I would maybe have
to just punch it in the face I'm I'm I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not asking I'm
not I'm not asking anyone to punch him
in the face careful right but what
eventually happens is another guy will
come on your feed and he will have a
better job so this happens with sisters
they do kind of you know then message
that guy to you know get to know them
you know I'm just going to talk to a few
people here and there and if someone
makes one little mistake or I'll move on
to the next one that's it that's what
guys do too and you know what is as if
Allah is teaching us to listen oh that
husband you loved he's gone now that
wife that was never going to leave you
she's gone your kids are going to get
married they're going to go so I've had
situations where they'll wear the hijab
and then later on they'll they'll take
off after the date and stuff even men
that are into their 30s and a really
lonely these apps make it so difficult
you know the time to camel there's no
now now it's
no I have to do everything in my power
so this camel doesn't get lost maybe
that's why you're not getting married
because you don't have trust chasing you
shouldn't Chase it you should have faith
in Allah and um he's got his set it up
in please like if it doesn't work out
just give your give my daughter back to
and he's crying and he's crying he's
very upset and all the comments were
saying is not oh what do you mean
give like she belongs to sh up man like
Western women may not tell you but like
if a man you know is if he's not like
protecting you in that way but like from
other men's gaze there's always going to
be like a form of resentment within that
woman's heart she might not recognize
shows through her thank you what you
send she can come and say um oh that's a
bit weird well you get that bro weird
what the freak is weird man you're
you're bloody weird I've I've asked you
in an honorable way to speak to your
bloody father you calling me weird
you're the
weirdo Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping the click the
link and donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inah
welcome to another episode of The Bitter
truth show today we're going to be
talking about something very interesting
which is um Muslim dating apps or
whatever you want to call it for that
matter um yes I have my personal
experiences with them actually when I
first came to Islam but I'll tell you
guys about that a bit later uh so we
have alhamdulillah brother M here we've
got Michael who's a regular M and we
want brother M to be a regular as well
inah we've got new sisters um sister
lucky yeah and sister an and sister Hala
may Allah bless you guys in we would
like you guys to be regular as well for
your contributions and bra say if you're
watching at home this this EP this show
uh was started uh the aim is to preserve
the marital unit there's a outright
attack on the marit uh marriage as a
whole divorces are happening uh so it's
there to you know understand each other
better understand the opposite agender
better and yes inshallah it saves homes
and houses uh inshallah and we stay
married to a brother and sisters so uh
today it's basically when it comes to um
these Muslim dating apps um the pros and
the cons uh I can go into a lot of
discussion about it as well but a lot of
people are shy actually like for example
if I was to ask this was actually shun
at one moment like people think like if
they mention like oh I got married on
this app it's like some a you know so I
don't know if you guys want it's a
personal matter but have you guys ever
on it uh yeah I've read a was much
before well okay we'll beat that don't
worry but yeah well just don't mention
the name but we'll beat it yeah okay so
you've been one of those apps okay so
because I was looking to get married and
and I thought like you know I've heard
about it and I thought okay I might find
a good brother there and it was not good
why not tell us your experience what
happened um I felt
like I feel like the the men on there
were looking for zena I I genuinely
belied like that's what they were
looking for they weren't they weren't
serious they weren't
committed and I just I it it didn't feel
serious to me at all whatsoever like and
I and the men on there
were I don't know I just didn't I I
didn't like it I didn't like it and I
after after a day I just went off it
because I just the conversations were
they weren't very sloy basically they
were were they were they like like were
they was any decent men out there or
like there was this there was this one
guy who asked me like what do you look
without your sorry what do you look like
without your hijab and like can I see a
picture and stuff like that like so yeah
there is there is an opinion on that but
not over the app I think it's when they
come and you know come speak to the
father Etc there's I think H that hold
the opinion that the woman can um show
the hair dress up before marriage yeah
Mar so H so I'm very sure because I'll
be honest with you is that even correct
Islamic can said to one of the
companions that go and see something in
her that will incline you to marry her
so they derive from that for example you
can see just so you guys know this is
Islam by the
way ankles you can see the arms uh she
can wear she can wear a type of clothing
that's baggy but just gives you an idea
um and she show her hair yeah this this
is actually yeah it was like you
couldn't see anything like you had to if
that's at your discretion but it's for
example if I was to go and propose to a
sister at the house the father had a
couple of meetings promising and I said
look I would like to see without hijab
it is allowed if you follow that opinion
it's totally allowed then like what if
you decide like don't want to Mar here
but you've just seen her without okay
but so so so so so islamically that
opinion says that it is allowed so if
things are looking promising and it's
had the discretion of you if you say I
prefer not to okay no problem the man
will decide okay I'm going to you know
it's fine okay it's not that deep or or
I have to I want to see so if but if you
follow a different opinion say no I
don't CH it's totally up to but it is a
valid valid opinion um
it's it's it's is it based on of the
Prophet when he said to said a companion
go and see something in her that will
incline you so they derived from this
that maybe the anle to get an idea like
the risk to yeah so to a certain extent
um and H are usually quite strict so
they allow so yeah but yeah that's
that's a an issue not that I'm saying
it's wrong because you have a right to
say no I don't have to yeah so okay that
was your experience sister an and
sistera and you guys well have you have
you been on the app sister or any kind
of app I haven't personally been on any
app but um from what I've seen from
friends and you know family that do use
these apps I do believe that these apps
do um you know lead you to Zena but
before that what actually happens is
when you look for someone you're looking
for get to get married on the app right
so when you look for your you know
future spouse there certain things you
look for right on your feed you have
people you know like if if a sister's
looking for a husband the guys will be
coming up with you know they'll have
their like what they're working as their
financial status and all of that now
when you start talking to that one
person person based on you know their
financial position what they look like
their age Etc it all fits your criteria
but what eventually happens is another
another guy will come on your feed and
he will have a better job now there will
always be someone better so what happens
eventually now is you're going to you
know so this it happens with sisters
they do kind of you know then message
that guy to you know get to know them
and then there's another third one that
comes up now he has he has better money
different yeah exactly so what happens
now is you're juggling bit I'm going to
use the word juggling because that's
what it is you're now talking to three
different guys but when you're asked
which one you you know you you want to
go for you don't know yeah now you keep
talking to all three of them and
eventually what happens is conversations
you know start to lead to oh you know I
want to see a picture and this is where
I've seen pictures videos It All Leads
to everything and in the end what
happens is you're still not sure so with
apps I feel is like you will come across
someone who will fit your criteria of
you know who you want to marry but there
will always be someone better so it does
lead to you not being sure not
deciding as I was going to say I think
there should be like guidelines uh on
the the issue is these apps they don't
they don't care about that they say
they're Islamic apps I've been on quite
a few of them um in in the past right
and um the the stuff I've experienced is
crazy like they just want to make money
out of it that's all it is they don't
follow they're like they're like you
know just normal dating apps but just
Muslim version that's not the case
though disagree with this because my
friend I used to work with her okay I
found her in the supermarket she's like
pregnant and I'm like wow
congratulations when did you get married
and she a few months ago and I've moved
to Manchester as well and so I was like
how how did you get married like how did
you find this fell and she's off this up
yeah and she's like honestly I was on
the app for like 6 months straight like
I put my effort in into it and then when
I stopped putting effort into it I just
let Allah kind of drive it and then for
some somehow I found this guy when I
lost room on on the app from the app
yeah Sheed a guy I found her there in
the supermarket pregnant and I was like
who the issue with that is the exception
doesn't make the rule so what do you
mean from personal experience it's like
every hundred woman I've spoken to one
of them might be actually what I'm
looking for most people on apps just
from personal experience right they're
not looking for like a long-term
relationship and I know Sister ly said
um that the men on there they're quite
like they want something else right but
from my experience women also want that
the stuff I've seen that has been
messaged to me is like
insane as as a brother said I'm a
good-looking guy so you know two guys M
you're a good looking guy but you don't
want two wives what's going on that's
with everything you have to sift it out
like if you're looking for a nice car a
specific car you have to go everywhere
and look for that specific car you can't
just expect every person on an app
that's going to these with these apps
you need I think a higher sense of like
um strong will cuz it's easy to fall
into Z I believe when you get into these
apps you sort of lose a bit of your
innocence by the way guys are messaging
you girls are messaging me Etc and to be
honest I found like really good people
on the app it just didn't work out do
you know what I mean Ste apps just
everyone just stealth apps I said this I
said this in the previous episode um
yeah brother I'm not going to lie you're
right when it's when it comes to the
marketing with it is the same as it's
the same as Tinder Bumble pinge it's
just as Muslim at the front that's it
obviously there is the exception you do
have you do
have you all have the friends that will
be able to find their partner at the
same time they just like they're just
not good like it's going to Pro promote
zeni it's going to promote all different
things that all the same things that
bumble Tinder and so it's just stay away
from it and you know and I um sorry to
call off that's right I said in a
previous episode about um obviously you
don't have you don't have to uh believe
uh when it comes to the genetic mixing
of when they can pick and choose who you
have kids with and you have no idea they
give you a selection of people for you
to swipe you don't actually get to pick
who you're swiping at all you just come
across the person who's the best looking
in your Bunch that's it when it comes to
the questions about taking your hijab
off that's wrong like like fine
obviously um the companion but at the
same time I I just I it's ill it's the
ill intent it's not for the right reason
I genuinely believe like this it wasn't
for for the fact that I want to see what
you look like like before I make the
decision to marry you I felt like it was
more of like like he was sexualizing and
objectifying of course is He's not cuz
he's not sitting there he's not sitting
there in his home I'm really you know
like I'm really looking for a wife and
I'm doing this out of the goodness of my
heart
notbe majority of
time opinion I like the Muslim go on
there are looking for for obviously
going on there for Muslim women but they
also going on there they're not they
they would go on Buble they would go on
Tinder they would go on hinge but
they're not going to find a lot of
Muslim women that they're going to be
interested in so they just go on the
Muslim one to find girls that they
personally find attractive and they're
going to have the same motives as the
men on the three ones that I've just
repeatedly mentioned as well with these
apps you have to weigh up right is there
more benefit to the um or is there more
disadvantage and I know you said you're
we friend wait let me let me let me
finish let me finish so with what you
was it your friend you said you saw he
was pregnant so that's one case of it
working out positively right I can
mention to you now a million other cases
where it's end up in divorce a baby out
of wedlock advised me to that no fair
enough but that no I understand that but
that's sure everyone's got personal
personal experiences right from my
personal experience and hundreds of
others have spoken to about this and
seen on Tik Tok they've always said it's
so much fitner having that much choice
on an app it isn't good for your your
brain the way it's wired you thinking
you're thinking 100% you're seeing a
pretty girl you're thinking yeah she's
talking to me I'm the you know I'm I'm
popular check me out build your ego 100%
for men
especially even for women like let's say
you have a lot of options uh like all
these men have like I don't know how I
forgot how it works but I guess swiping
right on you uh you yeah like all these
guys want me I can have whoever I want
so you know I'm just GNA talk to a few
people here and there and if someone
makes one little mistake or move on to
the next one that's it that's what guys
do a real like connection formed with
one person this like a trust
me it's a false sense of reality like
sister said Allah bless spot on when it
comes to this it's it's the the um
comparison is the greatest D show of for
joy and this is exactly the biggest
problem we're facing today bro just just
imagine like and I give this example
like I say imagine bro I bring you fruit
yeah and the fruit is
called give me a name not Apple Man
something different mango mango no I'm
just make it up let's call it make it no
the fruit is called Lulu let's call it
Lulu this is amazing fruit called Lulu
and I'm like bro try this man this Lulu
fruit is amazing and you take a bite and
you're like oh my gosh this is hanging
yeah now you're happy with Lulu yeah
sounds like a a woman yeah it's it's a
fruit yeah so you're happy and you're
like this is good now you go and then
and somebody com say to you you see that
fruit that he gave you got the same one
try this you're try and you like bro
that one was dead and then imagine try
another one and another one another one
now you're not happy with the first one
that's my point there's too much Choice
there too much option you a full sense
of reality and not only that when you
have think you have that kind of option
that where oh yeah that person like me
that's person like me and it gives you a
false sense of reality and now you're
making decisions based on that and it is
so detrimental now I agree with s Alma I
have heard the story success yeah yeah
so what I've done is and I broke it down
to because in the marriage documentary
we actually went Undercover on these
apps by the way we went full out
undercover we had we had sisters to get
married and a brother and they would go
and we will see that for example the
Dynamics the sisters um get into know a
brother and I I come and go by the I'm
her um her brother yeah just I'm in the
conversation brothers were bouncing oh
is it oh why I in the conversation for
yeah I'm not interested in this so we
did a case study we went deep deep into
the algorithms the words that they use
and when we come out with our findings I
think it's in episode three or four I
released this where we try to go and
speak to owners and say these are our
findings why using these terminology why
is the video why this and that Etc so
why just to assess is this good or bad
there is possibilities like you said I
know of people who actually got married
so what it brought me down to is the
following is that generally they are
harmful and I'll tell you my experience
in 2013 yeah generally they're harmful
but if you have a good relationship with
Allah subhana tala and you fear Allah
and and you still not don't you're uh
immune from Zen by the way you should
always have your guards up but it can be
a means that Allah finds you someone
through that it is possible do not
disregard I tell everybody when you're
looking get to get married try it it
might be I know practicing brothers who
found good sisters or good Brothers
through there it's a possibility but
there is a great danger with it there's
a great danger when I was a new Muslim
in 2013 I I I didn't know any Muslims
Etc I just knew these apps I went on to
this yeah bro let me tell you something
yeah bro let me I came from a jilia yeah
all this kind of nonsense I would be I'm
ashamed of I'm proud of it partying
girls all this kind of stuff but I came
and W bro I repented I sto I said to
myself never ever am I touching a girl
in ever inshallah and bro I would go to
these apps Muslim girls bro that I would
meet and by the way I didn't know about
this whole speaking to the guardian I
was like okay I'm meeting there for the
intention of marriage I didn't know
about his Guardian so it was early
stages for me and bro well if you knew
what they were calling
to as a man bro I had to literally know
better and be like like I I and it
disappointed me so much that cuz I had I
held Muslim women hijabs in high regard
on the apps on the
app call to me it shattered me ins side
I lost hope cuz I'm coming from a j of
girls inappropriately dressed okay we've
lost hope in them you come and you see a
woman in hijab and then she's calling
you to Haram bro do you know what it did
to my IM Rumble bro I was like like
shook me to the court and I hated the
app I came off it bro cuz anyone I would
meet either bro they're trying to touch
my hand they bro they moving funny that
so much so I had to correct them and say
I have some shame I bro as a man I had
to tell the sister in hijab sister hello
like you have observing you know and I
realized to myself bro hijab is not what
you it doesn't mean it doesn't mean I've
learned my lesson it's the individual
not only I don't care if she's wearing a
motorbike helmet it means nothing to me
because that is a relation between I'm
so sorry sounds mad yeah I know sisters
in NS they wear to do mad stuff so their
face is not identified yeah so I'm not
seeing all of them there are good
sisters who observe the do not make
judgments on appearance that's what I'm
going to say that was my experience but
it is plausable my experience is similar
sorry sister I let I'll let you speak
first um I also think it comes down to
your near as well you know there's um
you know in actions are only by
intentions and I think you have to be
very strong minded when you go on an app
and you start to talk to people you have
to be very smart with what you're
dealing with as soon as you see a guy or
if a one's looking for a guy or man you
know either way whoever's looking for
one another if you automatically sense
any type of you know um if if a guy's
coming across with you as FLIR you know
flirtatious or just
basically how word it um I feel like you
have to have your guard you know just a
desire of lust away from it leave it end
that conversation and just leave it
there that way it won't go to an extent
where you fall into Z so I feel like it
comes down to your intention as well and
your intention will only be strong if
you have a strong relationship with
Allah you know if you have that you got
when you intend to go on an app I want
to look for this person and I don't want
to fall into any Zena so you have to be
mindful of oh this is what you can come
across and once you're mindful of what
you can come across as soon as you do
come across it you know that's where it
needs to start the issue yeah the issue
with that is um as I mentioned before
you know a lot of people lose their
innocence going on these apps so they
might have the sort of thought process I
just want to find a good man or a good
woman right but they lose their way cuz
they're seeing all this attention come
and statistically when you have this
much options it does mess your brain up
it's wired differently you're thinking
you know you got an ego on you you can
choose who you want so people lose their
way they might have a good relationship
with Allah but regardless people still
lose their way do you know what I mean
and my my my situation was similar to um
uh the
brother tell us what happened like with
you what happened um what just on the
apps yeah on the apps don't go to my
yeah what happened just I just went on
the apps basically and um I thought cuz
at that point I think I was like 22 23
and I just thought you know like I was
born in non-muslim city so let me try
going on the apps um gave it a go and I
went on like a few dates here and there
right to public restaurants and stuff in
Birmingham and it just they weren't what
I was looking for or they lied about
certain stuff so they by the way this
whole um filter makeup the biggest light
on this planet Earth and please tell us
because I'm telling you I'm just tell
story later cuz cuz you meet a sister
and like you're like you're not the same
person yeah you know what it is though
with that I'd Overlook that if the
personality is like good enough if
they're practicing so I've had situation
where they'll wear the hijab and then
later on they'll they'll take off after
the date and stuff do you know I mean
it's crazy man some of the stuff that
happens on these dates tell me your
experience that so one you wear a hijab
and she doesn't wear hijab have you ever
come across someone that looks totally
different like bro you're like you are
not the same person no because you just
wear makeup again is it same as the way
they were was
much yeah you know you know what is I
don't I don't go on dates with um women
who wear loads of makeup anyway because
I know that it's just a cover do you
know what I mean I know I'm just smart
enough to realize if she looks if she's
got this much makeup on what's she going
to look like in real life call me sexist
if you want that's just the approach I
have no can call you nothing brother
yeah I'll be honest I used to take wet
WS with me
I'm being serious I if this come to a
certain point where it's getting serious
I would say I would like to see you
without makeup like like straight up bro
yeah listen what what I just want to say
about the apps is they're only really
built for Attractive people as well I
mean when it when it if you go on there
looking like the Elephant Man you're not
going to like you're not going to get
anyone which is a shame um we're already
in an unnatural Society there's too many
of us so when you got the apps as well
on top of all of that that makes even
worse if you went back 5,000 years and
you were unattractive you wouldn't have
trouble finding them mate because
there's little to no selection ex again
options yes options whereas I just think
that's the main point really I mean it
is so it just makes it more diff like
for the Attractive people CR marks
attractive who people find attractive so
like symmetrical faces and whatnot but
for those that are unattractive they're
going to have a really difficult time
even men that are into their 30s and are
really lonely these apps make it so
difficult like you have you have certain
people who will find partner but think
about the people that it hurts even more
it's not worth it on a basis it's
moreful it's way more harmful the good
doesn't like the good doesn't outweigh
the bad that's what I'm saying and you
know picking up on the age yeah what you
said about like the you know there's
older people on there and stuff as well
it got to a point where all the sisters
my age range 22 23 24 they were all so
like they weren't about marriage just
about for making friends and doing
whatever right going lounges this and
that so you got to a point where I was
looking for women 28 29 30 even older
cuz they were more mature and like
they've gone through divorces and stuff
but I was just thinking bro I'm never
going to find anyone my age who's like
mature enough to like actually want a
marriage everyone's on here to Doss
about so that's that's my experience
with
it again I've got situations where my
cousins have married from musm oh crap V
out yeah I've had situations where I've
got like family who have married from
these apps and stuff and but it's it's
rare as opposed to General like
population
I think that's the important for yeah I
was going to say at the end of the day
whether what whatever platform you use
however like whether you meet someone in
real life whatever it is it's all of
Allah like it's all down to Allah you
make your duas and he will find someone
for you um you just have to have that
faith and that trust in Allah regardless
cuz there's a lot of people there's
obviously I guess I don't know maybe an
epidemic of PE lonely men uh who are
struggling to to find women you have to
have your faith in Allah you have to
trust Allah don't fall into the red th
trap yeah 100% like you have to you have
to um build that relationship with Allah
because Allah will put someone in your
life when you're not looking for them
when you're ready and when and when
you're ready is specifically when you're
when you've built that relationship with
Allah that's what I think anyway it's
very fundamental what you say you know
and I say this in every episode like a
lot of the episodes is that um we we
take we think that is in our hands this
is the biggest mistake we make so we
know the Hadi of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him which a man came and
he left his camel un tied and he walked
he was walking to the Masid I think and
the prophet said why have you tied your
camel and he said I have my trust in
Allah and he said that's good but tie
your camel now if you think about it
that Hadith teaches a lot of things and
the first thing it teaches is that the
people in those times had great level
oful to the level they thought I don't
even need to tie it we not from the dean
that you have to do you get it you can't
yeah even your door unlocked you have to
lock it today we have the polar opposite
which is
what bro bro forget lock your doors
forget you know the time the camel
there's no now now it's
no I have to do everything in my power
so this camel doesn't get lost maybe
that's why you're not getting married
because you don't have trust chasing it
you shouldn't Chase it you should have
faith in Allah have faith in God's plan
there is there is no maybe you're just
thinking I'm going to make this exactly
you know what that's why you're not
getting married they think that they
think that it is in their hands so the
analogy we give the example we give is
with the the camel it's that if you get
tying the camel they've killed the camel
the camel is dead cuz they're so fixated
in I need to make sure my camel doesn't
run away to the level where they've been
there and the camel is dead and they're
like you're brother you know you're
tying yeah it's done but your cam is
dead yeah you know why that comes
because there is no in Allah and today
what we do is what happens is the
following yeah is that we take the over
the I always mention this we take our um
false logical thinking over what God
command okay cuz we believe all things
are possible so what happens is sisters
come and say in order for me to get
married um I know let me show my hair
let me get my lips done let me get this
done ET whispering in your ear exactly
you know what's happening here there is
no look how much of an insult it is to
Allah that you are saying Allah I don't
trust that you can find someone for me
I'm taking matters into my own hands by
committing Haram and showing my hair and
putting makeup on Aki can you imagine
the insult the one who's created the
Heaven and the Earth you're basically
telling Allah who says that the birds
are fed with when they go out with a
hungry stomach and you're saying oh
Allah I don't trust you enough therefore
I'm taking the matters into my own hands
to the level of committing Haram sisters
do this when it comes to their beauty
Brothers do it when it comes to earning
an income so what this the same thing oh
it's hard to get a job this that I'm
going to sell drugs yeah Allah who
created heavens and earth cannot provide
for you so you're going to go and commit
Haram this is the problem we're facing
today no is left it's all in my hands
people think yeah I need to go to the
app you know I need to yeah maybe let me
be a bit bit flirty you know cuz
otherwise no men are going to talk to me
like sister an said yeah and may Allah
bless and preserve her because what she
said is zero
tolerance I'm telling you and I'm
telling you this CU Allah says talk
about his V as a reav who came to Islam
bro I was so sickened to the lifestyle
that I lived when I came to Islam bro I
had zero tolerance bro to the level let
me tell you something AK some sisters
will call me to outright Haram bro
outright Haram and bro I to myself I
would like you look you look at when he
was tempted by the woman yeah there's
three things he done number one he said
I seek Refuge of Allah from the curan
number two Allah says and he and we
reminded him of our favors remember
Allah looks after me Allah blesses me
Allah takes care of me and what was the
third one he took physical action by
running to the door yeah so the thing is
here that we have to know better and as
men that you know to protect yourself
from that zero tolerance the moment I
was speaking to a sister and get into
let's say one one week just get into
know some basic questions because if you
go to the dad straight away it might be
that she says I want to work and I don't
want you to work the moment I will
mention her father bro do you know how
many sisters run away can I speak to
your father oh he's away from Turkey can
I speak to your brother my brother is
what happen did anyone in your family
die you know and bro they would run away
there's a lot of women these days who
have commitment issues yes they don't no
they don't they don't want it look let
me tell something they don't want they
want a guy they they respect a man more
when he comes and says hey chunting drop
me your digits yeah they have more
respect to that guy than if a brother
came and said sister I would like to
speak to your W they they sh you bro
they're like speak to my dad I was going
to say I genuinely believe it is Dee
rooted you know I did say that women um
I I do think it's deep rooted because I
feel like it it does come down to the
fact that a lot of these women don't
know their worth um where they don't
know their wor
because Islam came to honor you with
rights um and it's like there's rules
and regulations in terms of like we call
it courting not dating um in terms of
when it when it comes to getting to know
a man for marriage and it's there for
your protection not for the it's for
your protection um because it's so easy
for a man to get into your head talk
because a man can say all these nice
words and and and manipulate attention
and you feel validated in that and and
then you might give yourself up to this
man like it's there's so much dangers
like for you to be able to get to know a
man without like let's say a Wally
involved or like a third
person remember if there's two people
like a man and a woman who are not
married if if they're alone together
someone needs to be there the third
person is looking over the situation and
people think in person that needs to be
the case but also in chat I've actually
had women on these app saying um do you
mind if my older brother old sister
whatever monitors the chat yeah that's
fine I prefer that over and it also
keeps the man in check he know there's
somebody like is going to be watching it
I need to be careful what I say to her
how I speak to her um he's he's going to
be very careful he's not going to cross
her boundaries because there's another
man keeping him in check I I will say
one keep another man in check yeah
exactly I will say one thing though just
from personal experience like these apps
have ruined so many people's lives like
from a religious perspective right um
like long term the way they view women
or the way the women view men it's
almost like they're disposable next next
next oh yeah I was chat to five G the
other day but uh I like two of them I'll
get rid of the other three that's so
common like it's so Comm I feel like
women look at men like their just like
ATM machine oh trust and women and men
look at women like they're just like
objects this is generally speaking
obviously
um yeah and the the worst thing is when
you go on these right I'll see someone
oh like she she's practicing the hijab
she's wearing everything appropriately
her her sort of news feed like her
profile all looks like good for what I
want right I'll speak to her and she'll
say the most craziest stuff and I'll be
like whoa I'm taking her back like the
reason I went on these app was to avoid
stuff like the other non-muslim dating
apps right I'm not going on that to go
on these apps and seeing like how much
of a how similar it was like yeah this
is insane this isn't for me yeah you
have to have your boundaries when you go
on these apps if you don't put
boundaries out up front once you start
speaking that keeps the man in check and
you also it keeps you in check as well
if you say you know this is what I'm
looking for this is what I want and that
you're not getting the same you know
you're not he's not on the same page or
you're not getting the same response
that's it that's the end of the
conversation if you entertain it more
and if you think that oh maybe you know
let's talk he might come you know he
might be on the same page as me or he
might change his thoughts his mindset no
but the issue with that is people people
like you might have the intention going
in I said this before you'll have the
intention of finding the right person
right you don't want to mess about it's
so easy for us to get distracted right
and it'll ruin your IM and ruin your
like your view and religion do you know
what I mean you know I was going to say
I and and so these apps are like people
fall in love so quickly nowadays be like
I love this person you know what I mean
it's all physicality and these exactly
that's what I'm saying and with these
apps it's all images right they don't
meet him in person until a few weeks
down the line so you're looking at this
guy thinking yeah he's goodlooking
that's the most important thing that
he's got bant is flirty that's it I've
asked so many of my friends like what do
you look for in a girl that are you know
just funny and just like you know flirty
bant good looks this and that I was like
bro like is she practicing though he's
like that'll come with time so you're
looking at it wrong there's also that
saying you are what you attract so you
will attract the type of person you are
like within yourself um if you have you
know that strong Iman and there certain
things you won't tolerate like you're
going to come across you're going to yes
there's going to be a lot of people that
you you're going to have to say know to
but then you're going to eventually find
someone who's on the same page as you
but what's going to happen quicker
you're going to find someone that's good
for you or you going to like destroy
youron it's it's I'm not saying I agree
like with like that I think so guys
what's the solution Sol solution is
having faith in Allah that's the biggest
thing right and what what the brother
said as well you should also search for
yourself if you're just sitting at home
you're never going to find it but you
need to have that faith in Allah more
than anything that connection these apps
yeah and you're feeling yourself slowly
drifting away from like religion then
you need to be like right like this
isn't right for me I'll wait a bit
longer maybe Allah will provide someone
for me but he's right too quickly people
are like just giving up on religion you
need to sorry giving up on faith con you
need to I see this if you put your trust
in like Allah says
inan he said that if you I if you put
your trust in him if you fear Him you
fear Him fear Him is what you fear that
you might fall into Z that fear means
that you're good conscious do you get
what I'm trying to say I will give you a
way out from places you will never
imagine at this Allah's Kingdom what an
insult to Allah that you don't trust
he's going to find someone for you bro
if you fix your relation with Allah your
Salah your fasting your Zak yeah bro how
many people do this stay away from major
sins yeah obedient to parents yeah okay
to the best of your ability W I'm
telling you the prophet said and this is
why I I emphasize so much in this first
do this then look at those options do
you get it the prophet saw a man and he
said what he wears is Haram what he eats
is Haram how does he expect his Dua to
be accepted so the point is what if we
fix our affairs with Allah Allah will
fix our affairs with the people
everything in that matter do you get it
we don't do that and that's why we know
the religion is made easy for us you
know why because bro if we put in the
hardship now like there's a verse in the
Quran Allah
says it's one of my favorite ay with
hardship comes eace if hardship comes
ease what's the opposite with ease
comes listen careful sh thank you listen
if with hardship comes ease the opposite
has to be true with ease
comes do you know what that means I'm so
sorry do you know what that means
everyone today is going for easy options
jump on the datting ETC what's the hard
thing to do in the beginning to patience
patience obedience to Allah Salah that's
a hard thing to do but if you implement
that hard thing now and stick to Allah's
legislation in the long run you're going
to have EAS but everyone does the
opposite which is what n let's just go
for the easy option I can't be bother
rush into find someone when you do the
easy now what follows in the long term
hard sh that is the key this is what
we're missing here everyone's jumping
onto this St first do this bro and look
I've been on these apps yeah I've seen
success stories as well yeah but I'm
seeing once you do that as a god
conscious person and you approach a
sister in a mean like in a respectful
wayam sister I saw your profile I have a
liking I would like to know some ask
some questions if you feel the same way
I would like to know you bit and I would
like to speak to your father done I even
done this when it came to like if I came
across a sister Instagram same I had the
same bro copy and paste and I would say
the same thing to the sister and we we
have a different topic about social
media approaching people social media
the moment you up and do that wrong that
protects her that protects you and not
only that it lets you know what she's
about because what you send she can come
and say um oh that's a bit weird well
you get that bro weird what the
that is weird man you're you're bloody
weird I've asked you in an honorable way
to speak to your blood father you
calling me weird you're the weirdo and
women you know some women there's women
that actually seek that when you
approach a woman like this it has to be
respectful but nowadays that doesn't
seem the case it has to be it has to
come across like oh you know you look
very beautiful it shouldn't be like that
it should be just like Brother Ali said
it should be I would like to speak to
your father but for some reason today
people women don't like that and I don't
know why that is but they want the EAS
sister you know I talked about the
hardship is what an honorable man
oppostion that way but they want
something that makes them feel good in
the moment we want instant gratification
this the dopamine fast cars fast hand
dryers Amazon Prime everything in our
mind is so fastly done Psy we carry that
into our friendship marriages because
we're thinking I don't get what I want I
can do something better friends he done
something I don't like I've never seen
any good from him the same attitude is
carried on how can we fix this though by
fixing like I said before there's clear
ay in the Quran pick I told people pick
your hardships either the hardship is
going to be praying to Allah not of
course it's not easy obedience to Allah
Etc the other hardship is what going
against his legislation and guess what
when you go against his legislation you
are in a state of Disobedience yeah it's
going to come at the cost of your and
not only that Allah says in the Quran in
Surah the wrongdoers will not be
successful you know what this means it's
as good as when you disobey Allah you
are putting Minds in front of you and
you're going to go on that path and get
hurt so the point is what
pick your hardship either the hardship
is going to come by you obeying Allah
following his legislation and then Allah
gives you a good ending or you're going
to follow the easy route which is what
getting into Haram and not fall into Z
he ends up leaving you he ends up using
you you're broken now the next man
that's going to marry you you are going
to destroy him because you have do you
get it so look at it so what what I'm
saying is which hardship do you want to
go for the one that's going to destroy
your life in this or the hardship that's
going to benefit you it's going to be
hard don't get it twisted Allah says in
the Quran don't say you're going to say
I believe and not be tested I was tested
bro I Allah tested me and not just me
many brothers I know to the point I felt
as if Allah pushed me off the cliff I
don't know why and I'm falling to the
floor and I'm asking a question what did
I do to deserve this but when you have
and say Allah knows best yeah yeah and
before you hit that
floor I've seen this with practicing
Brothers bro that Allah has a before you
hit that floor this much you're like I'm
dead Allah picks you up takes you to the
cliff and you you see a
p any brother or sister of sin who
observed Allah's laws Allah gave them
I'm telling you Aki the doors to
everything that's all I'm going to say
I've seen it with my own eyes I've heard
it with my own ears and anyone that has
disobeyed Allah's legislation I've seen
nothing but chaos and destruction that's
that's that's the thing as well if you
have faith if you have faith in Islam if
you have faith in Allah um you will
eventually get married and even if you
don't marriage isn't the most important
thing in life there's other things it in
you know what I mean in your life that
you need to focus on it'll come if you
chase marriage it's not going to happen
like according to what you want it's
Allah's will isn't it at the end of the
day so when you rush and go on these
apps and stuff saying oh my my age is
expiring I'm a woman I'm 20 I need to
find someone ASAP I'd say it's a general
consensus for women right it's like
they'll rush into these marriages on
these apps and stuff and then it doesn't
work out well ends up into can I can I
just mention sorry um you know Sarah she
was the wife of
ibraim and she was given hajer as a gift
and then SAR was like well I can't have
a baby so why don't you
ibraim Mar Haim and then we have is and
then is and hajim we left in the desert
so that's that side but then SAR over
years she was able to give ibraim alisam
a baby and she was in like her late 40s
I think mid 40s so you know when someone
says to you like oh your
you know you haven't had a baby yet in
your 30s or you've got an expiration
date on your room like please don't
believe this a faith incorrect because
just believe in Allah like Allah exactly
this is life you don't you don't know
what's going to happen in the future
that's what that's how we we go we plan
we plan our days you know but we don't
know what's going to happen we have to
go with the flow of Allah plan exact
I've got I've got a relative who's um in
a situation where she's not she's
reached age now where like she's
stressing about marriage parents telling
her you know you need to get married
you're getting older now this and that
and it stresses her out of course but
her mentality is she's just got faith
that's it it'll come it'll come when it
comes you can't rush into whenever you
go looking for something you never
really find it I mean like whenever it
always happens like if I'm leaving the
house and I'm looking for my car keys I
know it's a silly example but I'm
looking for my car keys I never find it
but whenever I'm not looking for myis I
always come across it or I always see at
the house whenever you're looking for
something it can never be seen it's
really annoying going back to what you
were saying about discipline discipline
and lack of discipline are both painful
only the pain for lack of discipline
comes after with regret with discipline
the pain is now and then and then you'll
Triumph at the end so that that's a
definitely an important point to
to like leaving the episode is uh you
know keep discipline because it's going
to benefit you in the future well can
ask you something you know um I don't
know if it's from the Hadith or the
Quran where it says um it's to get
married young right now to cuz a lot of
people use that when they're going on
these apps saying you know I want to get
married early this soon not to get
married Young At what point can you
apply that not apply that where's the
line for that parents also use that when
they oh all the time grandchildren this
and that as well and to be honest I I
don't know if it's a Hadith I can't
remember maybe the prophet he got
married at 25 if I'm not mistaken so of
course you should but as long as you
need to understand when it comes to
finding the one bro I say to people a
lot of people that you know finding the
one it's it's it's Allah and it sounds I
know sounds cliche and it's okay you
know okay but it's the truth
but when you when you it is it is the
bit of Truth you know the thing is when
you find Allah you need to understand
you know when you have the lance of
Allah you learn this you know Allah like
if you look into this world here
everything leaves you everything your
mom to your dad to the people and you
know what is as if Allah is teaching us
to listen oh that husband you loved he's
gone now that wife that was never going
to leave you she's gone your kids are
going to get married they're going to go
your parents if they came to my mom and
dad and your mom and dad and said he's
dead would you have to go in this place
there they they might stop crying and be
like don't love him that much and Allah
tell us in the Quran about that that day
nobody's going to know no one Allah is
basically trying to tell us the only one
that you have is Allah yeah you have
this to the moment you die the moment
you enter the grave the moment you
resurrected the moment you question all
the way when you cross theat there is no
body but Allah and when you incorporate
that in your life like Allah says in the
Quran if you forget my remembrance you
have a depressed life and if you um and
in my remembrance do hearts find peace
when you rely on Allah there's this
sweetness Allah gives you where you bro
you don't find it in a marriage but what
happens is you're so content with Allah
that when you are married it just adds
to it but if it's not there it's not
that deep but we've given that love to
Allah to the individual so when you give
it to the indiv idual and your heart and
love is connected to that guess what
when they go your love goes with it so
the key here is again it goes back to
putting Allah first and then you will
realize that Subhan Allah if we knew W
if Allah if we knew the things Allah
protects us from you know when we follow
Islam and we're strict like you know I'm
going to speak to the father or if he
doesn't speak to my father I don't know
nothing about it if you knew the of what
Allah is protecting you from you will be
in tears you will see what a majest the
word that I have that he's given me all
the stipulations and pro protocols to
protect my heart and to protect me but
we don't see it and because we don't see
the effects of it we don't have trust in
it so to me like in an nutsh show I just
believe W all boils down to obedience to
Allah and they'll be successful I was
going to say
like it's okay we're going to come
remember Sister forgot it's okay
remember let us know cuz it happen that
happened to M remember
one Michael was like and it it happens
to everybody okay yeah yeah yeah good
there you go that's why that's why when
you say you forget I just change your
topic so it just gives you more time
yeah go sister yeah I was going to say
maybe just maybe you're not finding the
one because Allah wants you to build
that connection maybe Allah is you know
holding that because it's a risk it's a
formal risk maybe Allah is holding that
risk back so you know you know you can
build you can attach your heart to him
first and then when you're ready then
Allah will give you that person yeah
it's all about being ready yeah yeah
100% when when you're ready I mean when
Allah is ready to give you your spouse
he will and Allah knows when you're
ready you might you might think like you
know I I genuinely believe like let's
say you come to a point where you have
built that TR that um that that in Allah
and that relationship with Allah and
you're like I'm so content I'm so happy
I don't even think about marriage that's
when someone will come in your life
exactly I've got an interesting story
here now I'll tell it I'll try not to
cry cuz the first time I told it I cried
about trusting Allah
yeah Listen to listen to this now you
can choose to believe me or
not thank you listen cool this is like
maybe three months ago I was working and
I was dead broke like like broke nothing
in the account no cash nothing the only
the only cash I had was A5 note um given
to me uh by a tip from a from a woman
from where I was working I had gone to a
Turkish restaurant and they give me like
bav and that for free cuz I go there all
the town I went in there and I gave them
as a tip my last5 note that I I was dead
broke I literally had nothing so I gave
them I gave the the waitress a
tip after that I had gone to work a few
days later I had I had done the same act
for another woman by taking the tray of
glass to her box from where I was
working and she had given me another 5
tip I swear to God I open my wallet I've
gone to put the5 that this woman has not
given me and a got nothing I gave my
last5 to clever I put the5 in my wallet
and there was another 5 note and the
same5 note that I gave to the waitress
as a tip for the Bava she gave me W I
swear to God I swear to God
like I swear to God it's the it's the
it's the when when stuff like that
happens to you it's one of those things
that reinforces your faith I mean bro it
was mad Allah does that because yuam
sory Allah says to him and if he was not
to see our favors he may have inclined
to it you know these things you know
when you ask Allah to increase Allah
comes to you Allah my know in
situations where one situation was so
Peak yeah like I don't want to get into
details pee bro yeah bro got me out and
and you know how I feel and this is this
is the best of examples for Allah I'm
just giving some kind of analogy imagine
you get into a fight yeah and every time
you get into a fight I just turns up
around the
corner yeah imagine into these fights
now the next fight you're going to have
what's going to be in the back of your
head Mike is about to come
round that is how Allah works when Allah
tells Yu Alam if he was not to seen our
signs he may have inclined to it meaning
that Allah makes you he gives you this
feeling where you know that he's got
your back and when you're in this
situation and you can't get out that's
what Allah says if you fear me I will
give you a way out from peace you can
you can't imagine so Allah makes you
feel and makes you realize that every
time he helps you like this can't be a
coincident literally Allah has my back
and then you have Allah increases your
slowly and slowly like that when it
comes to a point that when a woman like
you know one of the people under the
shade of Allah is a man who was seduced
by a beautiful woman of stature and he
says I Fe my Lord but do you know how
hard that is to for a man like I have
envisioned yeah like in my head I was
like look like I would love to be under
the shade of Allah yeah like but I was
thinking to myself like imagine I'm in a
situation you know and and as and as
Believers we should have this like the
to the urge to want to please Allah to
the maximum you get it and for us men
our biggest weakness weakness is a woman
so in my head I was like if I was in a
room I woke up and there was a very
beautiful woman and in my head I was
like you split second decision because
you're going to be like you're a man
isn't it in my head and I'm not want to
do this but it's just like it just mov
in my head in my head I was thinking I
have to do something very crazy
instantly I don't know why this came to
mind but I was like I would I I would
maybe have to just punch it in the face
asking I'm I'm I'm I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm not asking I'm not I'm not
asking anyone to punch her in the face I
would just think it in my face in my
head if she was try to CU it has to be a
split second you can't be thinking cuz
Shan's going to come did you get it
shayan's going to come in my head I was
like I have to do something no no no no
bro no no I was I was like I was like I
was like no I I was like I need to be
under the shade of was like what is the
most to save myself I was like something
crazy
like I have to something mad and you
know what's interesting there's a story
of a man yeah this it
like they me I think it's it's a true
story yeah so this man was seduced by a
woman and do you know what he did look
look look this is what I'm telling you w
if you put Allah first this might sound
crazy yeah you think mine is crazy you
know what he done this woman said if you
don't sleep with me I'm going to scream
that you're raping me do you know what
he did he said okay give me one minute
to go get baby he went to the toilet you
know what he
did Def SC through the window no no no
no no no you know def he defecated and
he put the all over his body and he went
listen to me listen to me listen to me
listen to me yes yes yes no no no no in
the toilet scooped he put it he put look
what he did is in in nutshell he used
some kind of you know impurity on
himself and he went and the woman
screamed and ran away well look look it
might sound crazy maybe some people
don't have the I don't know where it
happened story this is a true story and
it was said that they said that after
this time they would say that we smell
nothing but musk off this guy now for
some people it might be like yeah
whatever I have full and trust that when
a person puts Allah
first Allah will honor him in certain
ways he could have easily come and say
oh but Allah he for she forced me and I
just had to do the de that's not that
bad bro which one was bad me punching in
the face or this one is the brother in
question you by any
[Laughter]
chance
sister Sima so you said about for
example your friend was on this marriage
up here about 10 minutes 5 10 minutes um
would you are you considering on like
exploring that idea so I I have and I
did get on with someone and he was
lovely
but can I be honest you can be honest as
long as you're not exposed in any
sense he has he wasn't leading I was the
leader oh my God and I don't like that
you what you mean by that like so my
father whenever I have yeah like if if
if I my dad stay off and um we want to
do something I don't need to plan
anything I'm the princess I'm the in the
car chilling alh my father he's like
we're going to do this and we're going
to do that and I'm like yeah you know
this is awesome with him it's like I
have to talk to him like I told him look
I'm into these things but don't ask me
I'm into besze every month I go through
this phase just pick something for I
love wom like that like like like like I
would rather have Take the Wheel because
I don't want to take that's in your this
is this is your feminine nature you want
a man you want a man this is what I'm
saying men are women these days it's
disgusting well I listen I think this
guy is amazing but he's not there's a
lot of passive Muslim men and it is a
problem no no of course not it's just he
did he but this is you know this is the
interesting point because at the end of
the day like your your your father has
treated you like a princess and you want
the next man to treat you like in what
sense though yeah the thing is you want
someone that's going to lead you yeah
like decide what the plan is and of
course no plan the day this is what
we're doing exactly even pay for no he
should pay for you sister why should he
pay for you as well like if I'm doing
something wrong if I say something wrong
my dad will correct me yeah yeah there
there's a lot of there's a lot of Muslim
men you know where you know you know can
I can I can I say something do you can I
can I say something to all the sisters
in the building here yeah do you agree
that as woman you you guys look for that
being corrected this might sound a bit
mad this might sound a bit mad yeah no
no one one second just this might sound
a bit controversial yeah being put in
your place but no I don't mean in a way
respectfully no no no yeah that's what
it is look look look look look for
example let me give a scenario because
the thing is here we need to be a bit
real yeah for example if if a man sees
his wife wearing lipstick and he tells
her like you know can you take it off
please like I I don't appreciate yeah
and if she says no I'm going out like
you're not going out take the
off if your husband said that to you can
you just tell me how would you feel I
would tell him why you telling me he
tell because I didn't want to guys this
you yeah so I say okay cool I'll take it
off that's good your reason because he's
gave me a reason there's been a
conversation okay that's true true but
if he if you don't understand it like
look it's just for me but he says
wouldn't do that no I know you wouldn't
but if a woman was to do that and the
husband said you we're not going out
until you take it
off um as as as as a woman personally
for me I I would take it off because um
cuz there's a thing called and I
understand like I might not understand
his entire thought process as to why
he's asking me um to take my lipstick
off but like I have sisters so I I'm
very protective over them like if I if
it was up to me i' like the car my
sisters because I like cuz
there was this he said if you knew what
was going on in the minds of like men
men know men best the main wear a tent
you walk around in a tent exactly so if
my husband was to tell me that like I
would I would like respect like what
he's telling me because I understand
it's not coming from a place of
insecurity even if it is even if it is
insecurity it's fine it's a man it's a
man's Choice bro it's not bro this is no
but it's okay to have insecurity as a
man if I don't want woman going out
another man staring at her why why
called insecure for that bro this is
this ridiculous the non-muslim it's it's
the Western
Standard to a level like yeah go get
your wife sit on another man's lap cuz
I'm not insecure you're filth you are
filth this is this is how this is the
reason why the Western men this the
passport Bros they traveling into
different countries they they've given
up on the western women bro get out of
here man I'm insecure for telling you
not to dress up in a Min for men
jealousies should be encouraged to a
certain extent you know what I mean you
know like a women may not tell you but
like if a man you know is if he's not
like I guess um protecting you in that
way um but like from other men's gaze
there's always going to be like a form
of resentment within that woman's heart
she might not she might not recognize it
when she shows through her thank you she
she'll start disrespecting him to as a
man because you're supposed to be doing
your job in terms of not just physical
protection protecting my heart my my
emotion everything
yeah exactly under the care you're under
the when you go it's your father who
looks after you when you get married or
you go into a relationship you are now
given to the man and as a man you have
that responsibility the duty to you
placed by Allah it's so let's say
Devil's Advocate then women a lot of
women will say you know my body my
choice sort of thing I don't want to
wear
theil's Advocate I'm getting attack
right now that you have to detach from
that materialistic thing that's your
husband telling you something you'd be
surprised in Birmingham it's very it's
very common for like um women's like a
man like they wear what they want and a
man will like that other men are staring
at their women I know if I explain
myself
properly it's so common in lounges and
stuff you'd be surprised it's disgus
because like you're literally as a man
you know what's going through that other
man's mind and you're you're okay with
that you should not there's men out
there that enjoy showing their women
about the way I think the way things are
going ni a little bit s cuz like there
was a I saw a video of a Christian
wedding and the dad is walking a
daughter down the aisle and has passed
off her daughter his daughter to the the
group and um he's got he said to the
please like if it doesn't work out just
give you give my daughter back to he's
crying and he's crying he's very upset
and all the comments were saying it's
not that's beautiful is oh what do you
mean give back like she belongs to sh up
man like they don't they don't see the
they don't see the the the beauty in
they just see like oh what do you think
a woman you think she belongs to you
yeah what you saying about she's your
daughter of course like like but people
aren't ready to the man takes care of
the household if the man dies if the
father Dies who does it go to the
brothers or the uncle it doesn't go to
the woman the woman is there to just be
a princess and a queen well she has to
fulfill her obligations as well
obviously the Next Generation to give
birth to the Next Generation yeah yeah
exactly she's part of the family unit
she has her own stuff to do but she
should be treated like a queen as well
is it like yeah we need to wrap up okay
guys so basically you heard it um it's
up to you but like to us inshallah when
it comes to this stuff the apps can work
but we believe that the dangers are
greater we've had people who have had
experience please tell us your Force
inshallah till next
time the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana T
tells us that our books will be given
and every little at weight of Good Deed
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
a lucky person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allowed people to
pray you built a Masjid I never had the
money to build the mid of Allah you
helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you built
it donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra
[Music]
Rewards
for